well this morning Theresa May has
written a personal plea to voters to
back her brexit plan or we can talk now
to one of her most loyal supporters
there James Break and char who is the
housing secretary thank you very much
for being with us this morning and mr.
Brito so we've had this morning show has
no plea we've had this personal plea
from the prime minister is it too little
too late
surely most people have made up their
minds now on whether or not the deal is
a good one well I think there is a
choice that MPs and indeed taking this
message to the country on what is a
clear deal a firm deal in terms of how
we can move forward positively to see
that free trade arrangements to see the
end of free movement taking back control
of our money our borders our laws ending
our association with the coma Fisheries
Policy the Common Agricultural Policy
but putting jobs firmly there so it is I
think that clear message that the Prime
Minister is giving in her letter and
obviously as we look towards the summit
later today concluding the negotiations
getting the political declaration and
the withdrawal agreement agreed and
obviously then taking that to Parliament
for that further scrutiny I mean you can
see the choreography that was intended
over the last 24 hours when we expect of
course the EU leaders to approve the
breaks that dill her letter hitting the
newspapers this morning but things did
go quite to plan did they were the
Gibraltar can you guarantee that any
future trade deal with the EU will cover
every British territory everywhere that
considers itself to be British the Prime
Minister has been very clear in her
strong support for Gibraltar indeed how
she has underlined that sense of
sovereignty and if you look at what has
happened here look at the statements
that have been made the clearest firmer
support of any British prime minister
for Gibraltar not my words but the words
of the first minister of Gibraltar and
how as we look towards the next stage of
the trading arrangements how we want to
see that encompassing all of the UK
family and therefore it is with that
approach that we looked
the future and look beyond the the deals
and the discussions today and look
towards the conclusion of that
continuing relationship so I didn't
quite catch the answer to you add the
question about whether or not you can
guarantee that any future trade deal
will cover every British territory and
everywhere that considers itself to be
British yeah that's what the Prime
Minister has said that we approach this
next next stage of the trading
arrangements and the negotiation of the
detail that now moves forward from the
political declaration for the whole of
what you might describe as the UK family
and so that very much has Gibraltar in
our minds as we look towards that next
stage of the negotiations and how
nothing has changed from withdrawal
agreements how it is now moving forward
through the political declaration and
securing that broad trade deal that the
political declaration underlines for all
of the UK family now one of the issues
of course is that no matter what happens
here in Brussels today the real battle
is going to be back in the UK in a
minute I can't really see how the
numbers add up for that deal to pass
through the House of Commons so if you
can't get it through what happens next
do you have a second vote
do you have an election do you have a
second referendum do you leave with no
deal what happens well I think that
there is a deal that is in the best
interest of our country that deals and
responsive very clearly the wishes of
the British people in the referendum
taking back control of our money our
borders and our laws and giving effect
to the referendum results and I think
it's four MPs now of course to
scrutinize this properly but if that
does not happen then effectively you'd
be back to square one with more
uncertainty more division why I think it
is important that people get behind the
prime minister get behind the deal that
we see being being approved today and
allowing us to move forward as a country
on to all of those things that the
British people want us to do all of the
domestic priorities and that clear
message that we hear time and time again
of just let's get on with it that's what
we can do here and that's what I want to
see Parliament and
of the CMPs now getting behind as we
look to the future your perhaps one of
the people that Teresa may can really
rely on there to back her position in
the cabinet it's clear that you're fully
behind her deal so is the deal on the
table better than the current deal we
have with the European Union I think
that the Chancellor of the Exchequer was
asked this question that yesterday or
the day before and I think that it does
give effect to the vote of the British
people and therefore yes I think it is
now things have now changed we've had
that referendum we look towards a future
outside of the European Union and this
is a good deal for our country yeah I
think I think that given that the people
have now voted for us to leave the
European Union yes I think the EU now
has moved on therefore it is in our best
interest to secure this deal to look to
that bright future where we can to go
say our trading arrangements with
countries outside of the EU and yes
getting on with this now and actually
charting that bright positive future
that I know that we can secure and we're
talking about contingency plans little
earlier and you must have some
contingency plans so is no deal still on
the table is that still a possibility
yes I think I think you can we can
clearly say that work is continuing
firmly and at Pace in relation to and
though deal obviously it's not something
we anticipate there is the deal that is
here now that we want to see everyone
getting behind but I think it is right
and prudent and appropriate that we
continue those arrangements the
Chancellor announced an extra five
hundred million pounds in the budget
just a few weeks ago which takes our
total commitment to No Deal preparation
since 2016 up to four billion pounds 106
technical notices that have already been
published and therefore how we will
continue in parallel to ensure that
nodal preparations are maintained and
that frankly is the appropriate way for
any responsible government to approach
this but clearly we want to get this
deal we want to see this being advanced
we want to see the country moving
forward coming together
in this deal and getting on with the job
of governing on the domestic issues
which clearly people want us to focus
upon and why it's supporting this deal
matters so much and I also I want to ask
you about the case of natty hedges the
academic who sentenced to life in prison
for allegedly spying in the UAE I mean
this is a really shocking story it has
the British government being caught
napping this is obviously hugely
concerning for Matthew and all of his
family the Foreign Secretary remains a
very close contact with his counterpart
the UAE foreign minister and indeed the
family and obviously with Matthew and
his lawyers are keeping close concept
the Foreign Office we are doing all that
we can to resolve this issue positively
the foreign secretary with his last
conversation with the UAE Minister I
think took some positive sense of that
on wanting to see this resolved quickly
and speedily
but obviously we do want to see a
clemency granted to Matthew at the
earliest opportunity and we are doing
all that we can to secure that outcome
okay James broken chair thank you very
much for being on the program it's more
much